I'm announced Carly said I'm the chief
executive at Gore health and it's I'm a
dad I'm a husband and almost probably as
worried and and virus away as anyone on
this community I'm also responsible for
the well-being and safety of my staff
130 of them and many of those front
lines so my thoughts are very much
focused on the people at the front line
doctors nurses administrators cleaning
staff all of those are playing their
part to keep us safe really at this time
I get some of the key messaging that I
wanted to give and get through today is
with this virus we know that in its
first week is when it incubates and it's
the second week April the third to the
ninth that it's absolutely critical that
we observe the lockdown rules because
it's this week that the virus comes out
of incubation melea's and it's most
infectious so I cannot reiterate enough
and ask people to please play their part
in sticking to the rules don't move stay
home and only go anywhere for absolutely
essential goods or services going to the
shop or groceries or for you usually
exercise please be mindful of others
it's going to take a a nation of
conscientiousness for us to beat this
thing you know on top of it on that note
I think our community of East and
Southland and core have been absolutely
amazing at observing the rules and
sticking to them the roads are quiet
everyone is doing their best it's
wonderful to see so many people out
walking and exercising and doing all
those good preventative health measures
and I think we're going to be a physical
we've never been a fascination and
probably all our history so good on you
up to everyone
stay safe and look after yourselves keep
an eye out for those who are vulnerable
and our elderly out there and make sure
you
you get in keep in touch and make sure
that they looked after all the best
everyone stays safe
you